dice el diccionario que la identidad es
el conjunto de rasgos de características
y circunstancias que definen una persona
y las que la hacen ser diferente a las
demás y además reconocerlas con respecto
a un conjunto de otras personas
cuando hablamos de identidad lo primero
que seguramente nos viene a la mente es
en que familia nacimos quién soy yo
donde nací porque nací allí porque
inclusive nacer en una familia y no en
otra forma parte de tu identidad pero no
es lo único que nos define
también saber dónde nacimos
específicamente en qué ciudad en qué
país porque me tocó nacer en venezuela
en caracas
aquí en chacao precisamente y no en otro
lugar yo no lo sé pero eso forma parte
de mi identidad muy profundamente
también forma parte de la identidad
donde estudiaste donde te tocó estudiar
yo siento que haber estudiado en el
colegio san josé de tarbes del paraíso
que fue donde me tocó estudiar tiene
mucho que ver con mi identidad yo
estudié con personas que eran hijas de
conserjes hijas de panaderos hijas de
comerciantes pero también hijas de
empresarios muy adinerados estudie con
todo tipo de personas y me siento muy
orgullosa de haber podido tener esta
oportunidad porque me ayudó a ver la
vida con ojos muy distintos desde muy
pequeña
también no solamente con quién con quién
estudie sino cuáles eran mis intereses
qué valores me enseñaron tanto en mi
casa como en mi colegio que me
permitieron tener intereses particulares
desde muy pequeña y reconocerme que
había tenido una cantidad de privilegios
que muchas otras personas no tenían y
que por eso me animaron a ir apenas
cuando tenía ocho años hacer misiones en
lugares muy remotos con nuestras
comunidades indígenas en kavanayén
en la gran sabana en santa elena de
uairén para ser específicos desde esa
corta edad y de ahí puedes comenzar una
carrera de hacer todo tipo de
iniciativas sociales
pero también en mi vida está muy
presente el valor en la identidad que me
dejó el haber tenido la oportunidad de
hacer clases de ballet toda mi juventud
toda mi infancia desde muy pequeña
al incorporar ese arte y esa disciplina
esa danza en mi vida esa danza clásica
también me dejó muchísimos valores de la
disciplina del entrenamiento de lo que
significa además ser parte de una
coreografía y no solamente lo que tú
como individuo puedes hacer sino
ocuparte de que no soy solo yo somos
todos juntos que podemos y tenemos la
responsabilidad de aparecer en la escena
en un teatro
también el tenis me dejó muchísimo y fue
un entrenamiento para mí también en la
responsabilidad en la disciplina una vez
más en lo que significaba competir y no
solamente por mí misma sino también
competir cuando representas un club o un
equipo pero otra cosa muy importante que
también me dejó en cuanto a la identidad
es saber que aquí en nuestro país el
tenis es un deporte que usualmente se
considera para la gente rica pero yo lo
aprendí en una cancha popular el club de
tenis la paz una cancha libre totalmente
gratuita para cualquiera que quisiera
aprender ese deporte
y luego en la universidad en la
universidad metropolitana donde tuve la
oportunidad de estudiar ingeniería de
sistemas gracias a que mi papá podía
pagarme los estudios también aprendí
muchísimas cosas más allá de todo lo que
aprendí desde el punto de vista
profesional de sistemas como tal y ver
la vida como un sistema un gran sistema
siempre abordar los ojos con problemas
siempre analizando los como un gran
sistema fue la posibilidad de tener
amistades que hoy después de más de 30
años desde que nos conocimos siguen
siendo mis amigos del alma y además
saber que me siento muy orgullosa de
haber podido estudiar en una universidad
que luego me ayudó a abrirme paso para
estudiar en otra universidad fuera de
venezuela reconociendo mis estudios
desde la universidad
de sistemas de la ingeniería de sistemas
de la metropolitana cuando fui a
estudiar mi máster en la universidad de
loyola en chicago tres materias que
tenía que ver no las tuve que ver porque
había hecho mi ingeniería de sistemas y
era por el nivel académico que veníamos
tomando nosotros los que estudiamos aquí
en venezuela en mi máster en chicago
aprendí también el valor del mérito que
se incorporó como parte de mi identidad
para siempre porque tuve la oportunidad
de haber hecho este posgrado
precisamente porque competí en buena lid
por mis estudios y por mis
calificaciones con ocho mil estudiantes
de los cuales a 200 nos dieron la
oportunidad de estudiar fuera a través
de un maravilloso programa que existía
aquí que se llamaba fundayacucho para
los que lo recuerdan
luego en el ies tuve la grandísima
oportunidad de estudiar este otro
posgrado y aprender muchísimas cosas
pero me dejaron dos en particular una
que a través de esa experiencia luego me
animé a ser profesora del iese de la
cual fui tres años profesora pero
también ser hoy día parte del consejo
directivo del iess del cual siento un
grandísimo orgullo de participar siendo
una casa de estudios que tiene más de 4
credit acciones internacionales como una
de las mejores en nuestra región de
latinoamérica y así sucesivamente les
podría contar historias de mi posgrado
en ámsterdam que más allá de haber
estudiado con 32 seres humanos
maravillosos que cada uno venía con su
background de diferentes países con
diferentes retos innovadores activistas
atletas artistas emprendedores
empresarios una de las cosas que más me
llevo que se incorporó en maíz a mi
identidad es haber comprendido la
diversidad de los retos que cada uno
vive
amsterdam uno de los mayores retos que
tenían era cómo conseguir más espacios
para que las bicicletas se puedan
estacionar aquí en venezuela estamos
luchando por saber cómo podemos ayudar a
que todo el mundo tenga acceso a la
comida
así pues podemos seguir hablando de
identidad identidad también de la que
plantea trazando espacios con su líder
anacristina vargas que le enseña a los
niños muy muy pequeños desde muy corta
edad que es lo que ellos tienen que
rescatar de su identidad local como a
través de observar imaginar y
transformar ellos aprenden a rescatar
espacios públicos en los barrios más
pobres de nuestro país precisamente
porque parte de la identidad local tiene
que ver también con el espacio público
pero yo también quisiera contarles un
poco más de lo que es la identidad
emprendedora que es realmente lo que
quiero hablarles hoy yo me descubrí como
emprendedora apenas a los 15 años cuando
se me ocurrió simplemente por ver una
necesidad de quien escribía sobres de
tarjetas de invitación de matrimonio y
yo que tenía un talento que gracias a
las monjas del san josé de tarbes me
habían enseñado muy buena caligrafía
yo dije pues voy a hacer un negocio para
vender
escribir estas tarjetas y así a esa
corta edad puse un letrerito en una
imprenta muy importante de la época y
podía vivir y costear todos mis gastos
con ese pequeño emprendimiento luego a
los 19 años junto con otros queridos
amigos de la universidad fundamos gente
nueva una ong que buscaba rescatar los
valores humanos en la juventud y
especialmente promover el valor de la
solidaridad a través de un programa que
se llamaba compartamos que enseñaba
oficios a las personas en los barrios
estuvimos presente en doce barrios de
nuestro país atendíamos a más de cinco
mil familias dándoles esta posibilidad
de tener un oficio del cual podían vivir
y a cambio de eso le damos la
posibilidad también de adquirir sus
alimentos a un precio más económico de
allí muchos años luego de haber vivido
fuera y de haber residido decidió
regresar a venezuela fundamos la banca
comunitaria una es más que un
emprendimiento era un intra
emprendimiento dentro de esta
corporación que es banesco que nos
permitió darle crédito a más
cien mil personas y también abrir las
cuentas bancarias a 500.000 personas que
nunca antes habían tenido la oportunidad
de acceder a un servicio bancario en su
en su vida
yo pongo esta foto porque esto fue para
mí descubrir que yo también tenía otra
identidad y que esa identidad de todo lo
que yo venía haciendo en mi vida se
llamaba emprendedora social y hoy día me
presento como emprendedora social dejé
de ser ingeniero de sistemas master en
esto o en aquello yo me defino como una
emprendedora social y sé lo de whatsapp
foundation del world economic forum ya
venezuela sin límites que me dieron en
esta oportunidad ese reconocimiento y me
hicieron a mí encontrar una nueva
identidad para mí y para lo que yo hacía
por eso arrancamos el impacto a caracas
en venezuela en el año 2014 junto a mi
socio víctor de yavorsky a quien admiro
muchísimo y que me ayudó a sacar este
emprendimiento adelante donde hoy día
hacen más de 200 emprendedores vidas en
una comunidad donde estamos todos
convencidos que a través de nuestro
trabajo podemos cambiar las cosas que no
nos gustan y transformar nuestra
sociedad que tanto lo necesita es un
espacio y es una comunidad internacional
pero
venezuela también local donde todos los
que quieren tener un trabajo con
propósito todo todo lo que quieren
dedicarse a hacer que sus sueños se
hagan realidad tiene un espacio donde
hacerlo para todos aquellos que tienen
el coraje de actuar en lo que creen y
llevarlo adelante y estamos muy
alineados a los que son los objetivos de
desarrollo sostenible porque creemos que
es una agenda que compartimos todos los
países del mundo de cara a lo que
significa el desarrollo de todos los
objetivos que necesitamos para hacer
este mundo mejor de cara a la agenda del
año 2030
es por eso que hoy voy a tratar de
resumir les para ella para terminar lo
que son lo que yo considero después de
haber dado pues estos tumbos por el
mundo por haber tenido la oportunidad de
viajar y apoyar el emprendimiento en
tantos lugares
lo que yo considero que son los diez
rasgos y características más importantes
que tienen los emprendedores pero creo
que también son comunes a muchos de los
que están aquí el primero es que los
emprendedores no caemos en pánico
podemos sentir miedo por supuesto como
todos pero no dejamos que eso nos abrume
por otro lado abordamos la adversidad y
los complejos retos que el mundo nos
depara y nos impone con optimismo y con
esperanza
hemos tratado de salir de un modelo de
escasez y pasar a un modelo de
abundancia
nos enfocamos en las cosas que podemos
relativamente controlar y que queremos
cambiar
usamos nuestra creatividad y nuestro
talento para abordar los retos que
queremos cambiar para proponer
soluciones a las cosas que no nos gustan
para abordar y atender los problemas que
nos rodean y crear oportunidades para
los que nunca antes la han tenido
estamos fundamentados en valores muy
profundos los usamos los vivimos todos
los días la el coraje la confianza la
colaboración somos una comunidad y por
eso sabemos que nunca estamos solos
estamos convencidos de que juntos
podemos crear impactos
tenemos un espíritu de guerreros y nunca
un espíritu de víctimas y finalmente
siempre dejamos espacio para el humor
yo me quedo en venezuela en venezuela
nací venezuela le debo muchísimas cosas
y decidí que en venezuela es donde puedo
aportar más valor yo espero que juntos
nosotros podamos crear impacto
extraordinario porque la gente común lo
puede hacer hoy más que nunca en nuestro
país necesita que reescribamos su
identidad que rescatemos sus valores te
sumás
[Aplausos]
[Música]